the nuke impossible live-action movie is
out and it's everything we wanted it to
be we've got an exclusive list of the
major oMG moments from the new movie
spoiler alert if you haven't seen the
movie you may want to check it out first
and then watch our video you've been
warned watch until the end for some
bonus lol moments from the film let's do
this
Kim Possible producer Zane Devine
compared the live-action movie to Wonder
Woman but she considers it to be the
teenager friendly version that's an
accurate description as this is the
ultimate girl power film Kim not only
saves the world right as the film opens
but she also saves her sidekick
Ron stoppable from a major explosion a
lot has changed since the cartoon series
one major difference is that we are
living in the age of gender neutrality
and inclusion so Kim ditches the
cheerleader pom-poms for a soccer ball
when Kim shows up on her first day at
Middleton high she is surprised when
vine tells her that there is no
cheerleading squad she said that at
Middleton high they are all about one
thing and that is soccer
and Kim has no problem crushing it at
soccer tryouts proving that this girl
can excel at anything there has been a
lot of talk about Kim Possible's new
mission opposite some fans were not
happy about the new outfit for the fact
that Sadie Stanley was cast as Kim some
thought Sadie wouldn't be tough enough
to defeat shego others wanted the old
baggy pants and crop top from the
cartoon back but Sadie proved all the
haters wrong she trained in martial arts
for months to prep for the role of Kim
Possible her stunts are incredible in
the film she even referenced the costume
update in the film her new friend Athena
asks why she doesn't wear her old
signature costume on missions anymore
Kim says she thinks that wearing the
same thing all the time kind of felt
cartoony after a bit and boom just like
that she shut down the costume haters
besides its kind of hard to fight crime
with your midriff all exposed and
vulnerable you don't see Ironman in a
tube top and when you're fighting dr.
Drake ins evil henchwoman that's right
we said hench women okay now we can just
talk about the new communicator for a
second since the cartoon aired 17 years
ago there's a lot of new technology so
Kim and her
got some impressive tech upgrades first
Kim's not using her handheld
communicator anymore she now has a
pendant on a necklace around her neck
that allows her to communicate with
Wayde at the push of a button when she
pushes the button a hologram shows up
with various blueprints and cypher
layouts its interactive and we have no
clue how it works but it's a super
important element in Kim's
crime-fighting oh and apparently there's
something called villains to Graham
which dr. Dragan pulls up on his
smartphone
it's like Instagram for villains where
they post sick pictures of all their
impressive villain layers the film also
introduces elements of cyberbullying dr.
Drake in films Kim stuck in an electric
eel tank and blasted out on the web
he's hoping she'll be made fun of with
cruel memes but back to the communicator
it also controls Kim's high-tech bedroom
with a touch of a button on her
communicator necklace Kim can open a
wall in her bedroom to reveal her secret
weapon stash not only does it store
several grappling hooks her jetpack and
her laser lip balms it also has her old
costume on display after commenting on
Kim's costume Athena grabs Kim's laser
lip balm thinking it's actual lip balm
and nearly blows a hole in the wall with
the laser Kim also has a very stylish
wardrobe which is on a track that rolls
out when she pushes a button the
production designer Rachel Meyers drew
inspiration from the iconic 90s movie
clueless kids bedroom is a fun combo of
high-tech gadgets and all of the normal
stuff you might find in a teenage girl's
room now we've got to discuss the
notable cameos in the film of course
Rufus makes an appearance as the CGI
animated rodent that hangs out in Ron
stoppable z-- backpack Ron finds Rufus
in a secret government lab and they
instantly hit it off the little guy even
saves Kim and the gang from being
vaporized by Drake ins forcefield
it was pretty epic when he flew up in a
drone that was remotely controlled by
Wade to hit the power button on the
force field
another major cameo was christy carlson
romano who was the original voice for
the animated Kim Possible show in the
film christy plays the pop star poppy
blue chrissy said her character is
pretty fun because she is giving Kim a
ride to a mission since Kim doesn't have
her driver's license yet
she had to rely on important people to
give her rides the biggest oMG moment of
the film is at the end when we discover
Athena is really a cyber human scent by
Dracon to still Kim spark when Kim busts
into Drake ins lair
Athena reveals her true identity but
then still warns Kim to get out before
it's too late then Kim decides to rescue
Athena from drinkin's evil plot to steal
her vitality but the part when Athena
saves Kim and sacrifices herself for the
good of all humanity gave us all the
feels
Kim Possible reminded us of the power of
friendship and the importance of being
who you are without getting caught up in
an identity in today's world of social
media and portraying the perfect image
all the time it's a crucial message for
young fans the film also points out that
it's actually harder to be a high school
student than it is to save the world
that is 100% true the Kim puns of course
we are all familiar with the classic
puns like communicator but they threw in
a few funny ones in the film too they
call Athena timet Asian she go even adds
a pun calling Athena a computer Sparkle
slime and the beginning Dementor
captures a scientist to make super
disintegrating uber slime but after it
must stuff it turns pink and sparkly
which really ticks him off dragans
toilet doll Dragan has a lot of funny
moments but our favorite is in the
beginning when he is in a prison cell
playing with a doll he made out of
toilet paper tubes and makeshift red
hair it was gross and hilarious so what
was your favorite oMG moment from the
kampala live-action film tell us in the
comments don't forget to subscribe to
the bangs to be the first in line to see
our videos thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]